qualcuno di voi
sto tele che un autore che mi piace
moltissimo la definizione dell'uomo come
tomtom ton politico cioè un uomo di
quelli socievoli di quelli che hanno
bisogno una relazione per arrivare al
alla fine della loro umanità
allo scopo ecco l'uomo in quanto essere
sociale ha bisogno di un canale di
comunicazione che è la parola per me
l'area semantica delle parole cioè il
modo con cui le parole sono nate si
manifestano si esplicitano dentro
linguaggio per me esercita un fascino
enorme ho scelto quando mi hanno chiesto
di preparare questo intervento tra le
centinaia di cose che si potevano dire
due aspetti l'aspetto del verbo osare
dentro i poeti e dentro i pittori
pensandoci in questi giorni
cercavo di immaginare quale immagine tra
tutte le grandi immagini che
costituiscono la storia della pittura
avrebbe potuto sintetizzare con maggior
chiarezza il mio pensiero e ne ho
pensato una che vi invito poi andare a
casa a vedere e leonida alle termopili
di un pittore francese di epoca
neoclassica che si chiama jacques louis
david
leonida alle termopili come lo sappiamo
dalla storia greca è un evento molto
antico che risale alla storia greca e in
questo quadro se voi guardate in alto a
sinistra troverete un particolare di un
soldato che incide un verso con l'ersa
della spada dentro la roccia andate a
sparta dite che noi siamo stati qui a
combattere e lo abbiamo fatto per
difendere le leggi della città allora
con questa immagine davanti agli occhi
voglio accompagnarvi attraverso quattro
autori dentro il mare magnum dell'area
semantica del verbo usare gli autori li
presento immediatamente sono omero
orazio seneca e uno più vicino a noi
d'annunzio
parto dal primo
omero non lo cito in lingua originale
dice ai pittori e ai poeti fu sempre
concesso di osare
che cosa nel limite del dovuto i pittori
e poeti hanno sempre goduto di un uguale
libertà di osare allora sono andato a
prendere un libro che c'è qui in
collegio appartenuto a un personaggio
straordinario don tullio bertamini il
suo dizionario di greco rocci attraverso
il quale ha compiuto tantissimi studi di
storia ossolana di storia italiana di
storia europea addirittura e sono andato
a spulciare un po da dove deriva il
verbo usare in greco e il verbo abbiamo
scoperto almeno reminescenze del mio
liceo classico che è il verbo to mao e
si riferisce a quattro aspetti nella
letteratura greca
lo usare come forza d'animo
losar e nella guerra losar e nell'amore
e in senso transitivo e anche la
rischiarsi a 15
inseriamo dentro in un percorso di vita
che ci pone con i nodi assiali più forti
della vita l'amore un'esperienza dalla
quale prima o poi tutti passano che
un'esperienza travolgente la guerra che
noi pensavamo essere una eredità lontana
nel passato e nella memoria dei nostri
nonni o bisnonni e invece oggi viene a
bussare in maniera drammatica le porte
dell'europa
e poi questa espressione che sir mons
eto'o ma avere forza d'animo
e cerchiamo di di codificare meglio di
decodificare un po questo verso di omero
pittori e poeti hanno sempre goduto di
un uguale libertà di usare
allora osare richiede qualcosa di
specifico quello che in matematica si
chiama il dominio il campo di esistenza
cioè fuori dal quale non si verifica è
la condizione della libertà per usare
bisogna essere uomini e donne liberi
cosa vuol dire significa che bisogna
uscire dalla massa
essere e qui interviene un'altra
etimologia che di origine latina degli i
greci quando noi scriviamo sulle lettere
no
egregio signor egregio dottor egregio
questa parolina viene dal latino e greco
cioè fuori dal gregge fuori dalla massa
di pecoroni
qualcuno che si distingue in maniera
eminente e come come lo esprime come
esprime questo campo di esistenza omero
attraverso due metafore quella dei
pittori e quella dei poeti perché perché
sia i pittori che i poeti in quanto
artisti hanno una doppia vista sulla
realtà cioè non si appiattiscono sul
presente riescono a uscire dalle
categorie dello spazio e del tempo hanno
quel genius cioè quel quid quella quella
cosa che solo un artista conosce omero
limita il campo ai pittori ai poeti ma
potremo inserire anche chi si dedica
all'arte della cucina ai musicisti
eccetera eccetera
seconda seconda citazione che ho voluto
fare dalle pistole 124 di seneca le
cosiddette epistole morales che tra di
voi è presente ed eri seconda ha
conosciuto che se ne che è stato il
precettore dell'imperatore nerone e
il suo nel suo ruolo di insegnante
ha coltivato anche delle amicizie
profonde con alcuni alunni alcuno dei
quali in particolare a lucilio al quale
dedica una serie lunghissima di lettere
e in una delle quali dice
noi abbiamo sempre disprezzato
quelli coloro che non sono stati capaci
o meglio non hanno avuto intenzione di
usare in maniera da uomini
la frase la frase in latino è ancora più
forte ed contermini musillo qui nichil
virili ter autori sunt dolori smet
quelli che non hanno avuto intenzione di
usare per paura della sofferenza cioè
potremmo tradurre il mezzo come per
paura del rischio
considerazioni osare è qualcosa che
nella mentalità dei romani a che fare
con la vita degli uomini
e non delle mezze cartucce ce lo dice
attraverso un avverbio virili ter
comportatevi da uomo a usuri è una forma
che noi magari non conosciamo senza
conoscere la lingua latina è un
participio futuro
quelli che hanno intenzione di quelli
che stanno per cioè esprime un criterio
di imminenza intenzionalità
predestinazione
cosa vuol dire che in questa visione
bisogna uscire dall'ottica banale
banalmente piatta del a cosa mi serve in
maniera pratica spesso nelle scelte di
vita nelle scelte di stato cioè vuol
dire le scelte di quando con chi
sposarsi quanti figli avere che lavoro
fare noi teniamo conto di un criterio
che autolib utilitarista cosa serve a
cosa serve il nostro l'indiretto
sull'anno quanti soldi ecco quest'ottica
è diametralmente opposta all'area
semantica del verbo usare che è un verbo
che non richiede come prima piattaforma
utile ma il bene mi avvicino e concludo
l'ultimo motore che volevo citare è più
vicino a noi perché muore nel 1938
gabriele d'annunzio il cui motto è
famosissimo no tanti ragazzi se lo fanno
tatuare memento audere semper ricordati
di sempre osare dove lo prende lo prende
da dei motoscafi che in tempo di guerra
erano utilizzati per bombardare i
sommergibili avevano queste tre lettere
m a s e si inventa una specie di motto
che diventa esplicativo di tutta la sua
vita
allora oggi e chiudo cosa significa
usare
significa uscire dal conformismo
uscire da una mentalità comune che ci
proietta subito nella dimensione
dell'utile e non in quella del bene e
vorrei chiudere con un personaggio
bellissimo che è vicino a noi vicino a
me soprattutto per età anagrafica
nato nel
1991 è morto 15 anni nel 2016 che papà
francesco ha recentemente beatifica
carlo acutis un ragazzo studente di
liceo di milano
morto in concetto di santità e aveva
un'espressione bellissima tutti nasciamo
come originali tanti muoiono come
fotocopie chiudo davvero cosa significa
usare quindi per noi concretamente nella
vita di oggi significa dimostrarlo nelle
scelte di lavoro nelle scelte di vita
nelle scelte della relazione significa
andare contro corrente faccio tre esempi
che con questo chiudo per esempio un
tema che a noi sconvolge tanto e quando
dei femminicidi occorre osare e dare un
paradigma di uomo che sia diverso con
gli amici è scomparsa spesso qualcuno lo
dicevano dal
dalle relazioni telematiche la fedeltà è
il tuo vicino che ti ti mette un like
contro dio ti dà contro attraverso i
mass media
allora occorre andare controcorrente
essere fedeli terzo tipo di scelta
controcorrente i bambini i bambini
io sono stato anche insegnante di scuola
elementare di asilo e mi sono accorto
che tanti bambini erano carenti di
affetto in particolare a quello della
figura del padre allora cosa significa
usare oggi andando contro corrente
significa usare essere autorevoli cioè
dare una dimensione di soli le solidità
ma occorre soprattutto essere teneri
osare oggi significa che siamo in
un'epoca d'oro perché non siamo come i
nostri nonni bisnonni cresciuti dentro
una dittatura non siamo imbrigliati da
paradigmi che sono estranei a noi
altrimenti io vorrei chiudere dandovi un
uno sguardo di speranza
il fatto che noi possiamo osare implica
la nostra libertà che fino adesso c è
garantita allora vale la pena davvero di
farlo grazie della pazienza
[Applauso]